well as pfizer is now approved for 12 to
15 year olds
local pharmacies and the southern nevada
health district are administering those
vaccines at a bunch of different
locations reporter kate houston spoke to
some local kids about possibly getting
the vaccine with their family
not only will kids be getting a report
card this month some will be getting a
vaccination card
i spoke with a few kids this morning who
say that they're excited to get the shot
along with their older family members
according to the southern nevada health
district it's important for this age
group to be vaccinated while they may
not be as likely to get severely ill
there is still a risk and they can
spread the virus now that many are back
in school and
interacting with their friends and
playing sports the vaccine can help
protect
kids and their families a few kids i
spoke to
are a bit nervous about needles but
still want to be vaccinated
it's best for everyone to have the back
seat so that they can be more safe
i'm excited that you can go into my
public places without having to wear
macs
anymore i think that this will be a
great thing
um so we can go to school and interact
and know that everyone's going to be
safe and they will get sick
get back to normal finally all kids
under 18 need to be with a parent or
guardian
and have consent before getting the
vaccine for certain capacity guidelines
to go away
60 percent of nevadans need to be
vaccinated we're currently at 47 percent
i asked the health district if this new
eligibility group will increase that
number
the answer was no so still the push to
get adults vaccinated
kate houston 8 news now